Mis señoras, está con sus padres, entonces el Nietzsche grita, Sr. Arais, mi señor
tiene mucho miedo de perros, se escondió atrás de papá, entonces el papá agarró
a ella y empujó, se está embocando, entonces el rector ya sabía que mi señora, agarró
la mano y dijo, pues la corona tenga miedo, tú vas junto con su esposo, y trajo al esposo
allá. El sábado a las 3 de la tarde estaban allá, empezaron a llevar todos para el crematorio,
entre 12 y 15 mil personas. Usted me puede hacer una pregunta, de dónde eran 12 y 15
mil personas, como usted la vio que yo entregué a usted, allá está escrito, todas las ciudades,
todos los pueblos, todas trajeron para Volodava, Volodava era el centro más cercano del crematorio
en su vida. ¿Me explico? y de allá, quien quemado quemado, quien vive, sigue, ya iba,
ya se fue, ahora quemado, yo me quedo, me pusieron filar, con el bloque, esto me hizo
el rector, me puso jefe de acá y jefe de allá, y yo hizo muchas explotaciones, y hizo serrucha,
cuando en Zegeberg, cuando se hace tablas, sale serrucha, tú sabes no, de eso yo exportaba
para el gueto de Varsovia, no era muy fácil, no todo, primero yo, primero Nitschke, Nitschke,
Lehmann Schick fue un deuche, él me ayudaba. ¿Las explotaciones eran por debajo? No, con
trenes. ¿Para los judíos del gueto de Varsovia? Sí, dejaron de entrar, para conseguir ese
permiso no era muy fácil, primero yo, después Lehmann Schick, una persona, y ya pusieron
el gueto. ¿En qué momento pusieron el gueto? Cuando liquidaron, cerraron eso, ya quedaron
poca gente, y ya la calle Wirck, la calle Wirck se llama, cerraron con tablas y con
alambre arriba. Entrar en este gueto era muy difícil, era pura gente que tenía palanca.
Otro día en mis herederas, Koglovich, veinte y doce hijos que trabajaban en mis herederas,
¿Cómo llegaron árboles? Era un polaco que se llama Antoniewski, él era uno de los más grandes
jefes, y tenía un poder, yo no sé cómo estaban juntos, con amigos, con Himmler, que Nitschke
a veces no tenía fuerza sobre él, y él era muy amigo de ese director Lehmann Schick.
Aquí estaba la heredera, vamos a decir algo en cromano, y aquí era la oficina de Antoniewski.
Entonces, nos citaba árboles para hacer, era Old Summer, jefe de quematorio, se llamaba
Old Summer. Los polacos quemaron puentes. Entonces, cada mento nos citaba especial madera
de este largo, de este tamaño, de este grueso. Entonces, como Lehmann Schick era persona mía,
siempre decía, esto tú tienes que hablar con Adam Rice, él es especialista en hacer eso.
Mantenía alto.
¿Pero ese cerradero no era del señor Eiber?
Eiber ya está muerto.
¿Y su hermano?
Quedó vivo, jamás de conmigo.
¿Eran dueños los dos?
No, conmigo nada más. Nada de con hermano, nada de con nadie.
Fuiste conmigo.
Entonces, ahí entré en viento.
Yo no tenía problema en entrar en viento.
Inmediatamente me llegaron a casa.
Nos llevaron mis dos hermanos.
Ya no, mi mami murió.
Mi suegro ya está quemado en crematorio.
Los cuñados ya están quemados en crematorio.
Dos hermanos ya sabían donde había bunkers.
Yo saco a ellos de mi tienda, de bunkers.
Ya era para mí un gran problema llevar a mis hermanos para el gueto.
¿Por qué?
Porque cogieron gentes que trabajan, que ocupan puestos para alemanes.
Y así mire, la gente que no trabaja no puede vivir.
La gente que no trabaja más no tiene derecho a vivir.
De esto hay mucho que hablar.
Voy a cortar.
Yo, con director alemán, logró.
Voy a decir un frase, ahorita aquí.
Seguro son gentes, para que no se trabajen, saben.
Es el viernes.
Ante lich-menschen.
Yo dijo, alemán.
Por favor, sáquenme antes de que podamos llevar a mis hermanos para el gueto.
Y fue cumplido.
Ahorita voy a decirte una frase, mire.
Cuando Ben Gurion declaró Israel por un país, Truman era presidente.
Truman tenía un socio, un judío.
Truman y ese judío tenían una fábrica de camisas.
Y Truman no tenía muchas ganas de declarar el país del judío.
Entonces él dijo, mire.
Estamos ya minutos antes de aprender las velas.
Que tú no declaras, el ruso se va a adelantar.
Entonces yo pendejé y declaró nueve minutos antes de aprender las velas para el ciudadano, Truman.
¿Sabían ustedes eso? No sabían.
Si saben sus gentes, entonces se saben, mire.
Yo soy todo mire agradable.
Y en ese gueto, yo tenía que llevar a mis gentes como chuchos, mire.
Como jefe de mis laderas llevar, yo adelante y ella atrás conmigo como soldados.
Cada día era notable traer para el gueto.
¿Cómo era el gueto adentro?
El gueto era, mire, cerrado con tablas juntas, viviendas y con alambres arriba.
Que no podían salir.
¿Cuántas calles conformaba el gueto?
Era 20 calles, 3 calles.
¿Y cuánta gente había en el gueto?
¿Cuántas personas habían dentro del gueto?
En el gueto, creo yo, mire, que eran como ya dos mil nada más.
¿Todos de Voldava?
Todos de Voldava, ya mire, ya quedaron, pocas gentes ya quedaron.
¿Y usted seguía viviendo en la misma casa?
No, ya no vivía en mi casa, ya estaba viviendo en el gueto, otra casa.